if you get distracted you get slapped
i wish that was a service i could pay
for because lately i've been really
disappointed with myself i have all
these goals and dreams but then i keep
sabotaging myself with all these dumb
distractions and i'm so sick of always
feeling like i could be doing more so
for 30 days i did something that changed
everything but first a quick warning
after watching this video you're gonna
make some drastic changes in your life i
cut out all temptations for 30 days and
followed an insane routine of 10 daily
commitments to build monk-like
discipline i slept very badly i'm scared
i'm worried i'm also excited and i know
i'm gonna come out being a different man
starting the day with no snoozing
putting the phone away meditating a cold
shower no social media distraction eve
from 1 to 6 p.m no cheat meals one hour
of podcasts a day tell my grandma i love
her that was a joke
although i should work out three times a
week no flippy floppy the bing bong if
you know what i mean and at 9 pm wind
down today was uh very hard just felt
isolated being busy all day but not
getting anything done really i'm hoping
things get better haven't you ever
wondered what could your life look like
if you actually did all the things you
said you're gonna do so i asked three of
my friends to join me on this challenge
but this is where it gets interesting if
you mess up once you have to donate
three hundred dollars to something you
hate i guess probably the kkk you know
that let's burn it that actually hurts
maybe it may be putin
you you can't fail i can't what are you
donating to the worst organization of
all the german tax authorities what i'm
curious about is like what's your
intention for doing this yourself i've
just fallen off wasting my life and
potential and it's just like because i'm
not spending it on the things that i
actually want to do it's just the lower
part of myself that you know the
addictive part the one that wants to
distract itself and yeah just escape
what are you escaping from
these first few days have been really
challenging and it's probably because
i have been going through a breakup it
was a beautiful time and
now that's transitioning out i think
something that i would caution because
of what you just shared is that don't
let the discipline become another
distraction or a way to not feel it's
called compassion this is not an excuse
though i think i picked the right time
to test my discipline and self-control
dude the first day of my challenge it's
been really amazing good for him after a
few days i moved in with a friend of
mine and his place was on another level
get it because it's on
the i felt elevated
watching the sunset from my
downtown apartment now when i cooked
beef the steaks were even higher okay
i'll stop the building even had its own
gym it's like the pool area over there
only attractive people and me and i was
building some momentum but there was a
big problem things got
too easy but i wanted to prove to myself
again that i can do really hard things
and conquer that in a weakling so every
week i added a mental toughness
challenge and the first one is facing
the biggest fear of all humans which is
doing nothing today i'm gonna be
meditating five hours straight how's it
going boys hopefully none of you messed
up i've been like crazy productive
because i don't have a phone i feel much
more calm much more present and
significantly more happier i'm feeling
focused and relaxed before entering this
challenge i literally had my first panic
attack i woke up in the middle of the
night and i felt like i was like i have
a heart attack and here's the question
that i gotta ask did anybody
kyle what had one of my habits was to
wake up in and go to bed at the same
time i have an eight-sleeve cooling
mattress and has a built-in alarm system
but on the weekends i had a different
schedule otherwise i would have been up
but so i think we gotta vote
i think it's fine i think it's totally
fine like that you just like didn't feel
like it sounds like it was an accident
pass but moving forward we weren't gonna
make excuses and although i ticked off
every single thing i wasn't really happy
with myself yet the workouts could have
been harder the cold showers could have
been longer i mean i think with all
these discipline things it's like it's
not about like the militant adherence to
what you said even though you're beating
yourself up about it a little bit leon
when you just track the trajectory over
a longer period of time and you can
relax a little bit into your routines
and into your habits so for week two i
decided to take the intensity up a notch
headed upstairs for a cold morning swim
[Music]
every day the same one
tonight i'm reading
[Music]
it's crazy how boring it gets
long days full calendars normally if i
was still in a relationship i would
watch netflix and calm down and which is
good too
without all these distractions and
temptations that not in my life i have
so much more time to work because it's
the only thing i can do that's
fun
every week i want to do another
challenge last time i did five hours of
meditation and this week i want to do a
thousand push-ups in a day only 940 to
go i have a full day of editing with a
tight deadline okay if i do a thousand
i'll be busy until 8 00 pm what i do
miss is just something where i can shut
my brain off just a little bit of an
escape i like to escape that's why i
love sci-fi movies fantasy movies where
you're just in a completely different
world that doesn't exist as a kid
growing up there was a lot of conflict
there were a lot of fights in the family
a lot of instability and that's when i
got into reading harry potter and
oftentimes you love a movie because you
identify with a character and harry has
this turbulent life and then all of a
sudden he gets a magic letter he gets
sucked into this completely different
world he can literally escape reality
and there's things like friendships and
adventure and a meaning to this all
while all the drama was going on in my
family i could just lock myself in my
room and read harry potter and i could
just leave everything behind and that's
why part of me loves to escape but now
there is
no escape other than maybe work that's a
thousand what a stressful day honestly i
have four hours of sleep after the
thousand push-ups editing all day and i
still didn't get it fully done
i even cancelled a trip that i planned
with my friends which i said i was gonna
go to and i keep canceling cause of work
today's sunday another video i gotta
shoot no weekend
again
i'm in the zone like i haven't been in a
long time the week's been going good
i'll probably keep using this for at
least 90 days man like i really feel
like really empty i've been in a pattern
of avoidance for like a long time and
some of these things are some pretty
dramatic stuff i find it also curious
how these simple little things that
we've decided are important to us and
how it can be a challenge to do them why
do we put off the things that we know
are best for us that's the question that
got me into doing this challenge why as
humans does it often feel like we're at
war with ourselves this is this little
nagging part of my personality that
desires it to happen now you know it's
like a little kid i have that part too
for me it's the one wanting to escape
don't you also have a part of you that
keeps you stuck for some it's the inner
wimp that chickens out whenever things
get challenging for others it might be
the jealous part that keeps ruining
every relationship or it's the inner
critic and how do we actually win this
battle against them
i'm not sure what challenges i want to
do maybe you guys have some ideas i have
a suggestion which you're probably not
gonna like but what if
you had to take two days off in the
middle of the week no
i know that's the real challenge i was
gonna say the same exact thing bro what
do i do like this is actually the real
discipline is like taking care of
yourself let me think about the reason
why you can't is the reason why you must
maybe the guys are right part of me is
saying hey this is 30 days of discipline
and taking time off that's the exact
opposite what are you doing you're
chickening out and then there's a part
of me that's like these guys have a
point there's an internal conflict that
i have
the day that i've been dreading the most
more than the five-hour meditation day
[Music]
then why do you sit in a comfortable
position
[Music]
what am i gonna do for the rest of the
day what do normal people do
it wasn't easy not being productive so i
made a to-do list of three things for my
self-care routine and the first one is
cooking something fancy which in my
opinion is a waste of time
[Music]
we're going to cook something really
fancy i think it's great i think you
need that asparagus potatoes salmon
it has to be really i want to do a
really good job with this oh no how's it
going so far i think i have a real
problem with social media i'm not gonna
go on social media until four o'clock
when four o'clock comes around i get on
and then six ryan try hand videos later
and it's like nine o'clock at night and
i'm just like dude what just happened so
i i set up the system where there's a
time thing and i'm giving the password
to someone else so i can't i can't i
will i will not be able to do it and
this just what has to happen i think
secondly i uh
it was time for a haircut
still cool yeah you're so cool dude and
number three i got really creative so i
asked myself what could be the most
unproductive rejuvenating hobby maybe
taught by somebody the exact opposite of
me there was only one option painting
with bob ross hey welcome back certainly
glad you could join us today i go right
into a small amount of the indian yellow
just make little little crisscross
strokes something like that
it already sucks just let it play and
bounce it doesn't look like his
i can't wait to see the before and after
i
really wanted to like it but i just want
to sort of dance this around a little
bit big old cloud it just sort of floats
around has a good time all day i've
always had this all or nothing thinking
what am i doing wrong like i can't do
something and not try to be really
really good at it you know clouds are
one of the freest things in nature i
believe just let them go it's this need
to control to have a grip on things so
let them have fun wherever you want them
let them go without this i don't know if
i would have been able to build my first
e-commerce business i don't know if i
could have built this youtube channel
but all this also comes with a huge
price and i'm starting to think that
maybe i'm
overpaying a little what if the real
flaw wasn't that i wasn't disciplined
enough i've certainly enjoyed our time
together i'd like to wish you a happy
painting and god bless my friend
that's really good you did the sunset
well it's just the clouds need some
attention
have you been going probably the best of
the last three weeks as far as uh how
how i feel i read 13 books in this 30
day period which is like wild i'm
actually a lot better than i was last
week what made the difference to you
kyle this week i allowed myself to feel
really bad like actually seeing that
part of yourself that's victimized that
feels disempowered and not just trying
to bypass that part of yourself we have
all these different versions of
ourselves i feel like that make us who
we are and they're equal parts to some
degree what was your big discovery this
week i don't know i think one of the
fears is what if i just go for full
enjoyment all the way through would i
lose my ambition and my drive what would
happen if you lost your
ambition
just
i wouldn't know
what's left of me
for the rest of the challenge the next
five days i'm not gonna be eating
anything nothing that was the last food
for the next five days i think it's
gonna be really challenging i have to do
all these other commitments on top of
that
i feel like it's extra cold when you're
fasted you can definitely feel the
hunger setting in you want some sweet
potatoes they have free hats here it's
pretty sick the mac and cheese now
what you doing huh cooking some beef
well yeah
[Music]
i don't want to tell you how good it is
you know what i have
germany water so it's like not fun
what you got now venison good for you
then
[Music]
i feel like there's a big hole in my
stomach i think i'm halfway through the
fast now i feel really weak and dizzy as
always everything was ticked off without
miss my productivity and focus were like
night and day compared to when i started
the last check-in call is supposed to be
today i totally forgot
oh so cheesy dude
for the final checkup look who i brought
in person
even rappers here from australia what do
you got to say
yeah and with only three days left with
this final conversation everything
changed and went into a direction i
didn't expect i had kept all my
commitments so far but i still felt like
i did in the beginning like i should be
doing more i think there's a common
thread amongst ambitious people because
their standards are so high so is that
the conclusion it'll always be like this
even after 30 days of cutting out every
temptation and focusing all in on work
it'll always be a battle against
yourself where do you feel like this
stems from
i didn't have an answer there's a book
called no bad parts which my therapist
recommended is really good
this book was the answer to all this
self-sabotage i had been struggling with
and if it clicks for you
your life will change
no bad parts by dr richard schwartz
explains that we naturally have multiple
parts or sub-personalities almost like
having multiple personality disorder you
might have an achiever a rebellious one
an avoidant one or maybe even a
self-harming one and they all want
different things which is why we're
sometimes at war with ourselves it seems
like i scripted this from the beginning
because that's how we kept describing it
all this time part of me is saying hey
this is 30 days of discipline and then
there's a part of me that's like these
guys have a point now here's some bad
news i wanted to get rid of that part
that kept holding me back the lower part
of myself the you know the addictive
part the one that wants to distract
itself and yeah just escape but the more
we try to suppress it the more it'll
fight back i think this part of myself
that i've suppressed is this
inner child that likes to play that
likes to be silly that at some point was
overpowered by the drill sergeant
because
it had to be done in order to be
protected
so they all serve an important purpose
when you experience a trauma that's when
a new part emerges to protect you from
that trauma and that drill sergeant
probably came in at some point during my
life because it had to protect
little leon
who maybe at the time thought he
wouldn't be loved he wouldn't be safe if
he wasn't disciplined if he wasn't
why have not done this earlier
that's the inner critic
because you didn't know any better
it's fine you're doing it now
you're doing great
[Music]
man somebody's cutting onions here
what's the part that you have been
trying to suppress
do you feel that part right now what if
just for a moment
you didn't shame it for existing but you
just listened to that part and asked
them
what's your story
why do you exist what do you need every
part
serves this purpose there are no bad
parts that's the last day
and with that the most productive 30
days of this year came to an end and
what i learned is this everything you
hate about yourself is just a part that
loves you and wants to protect you even
a self-harming one just wants the
physical pain to protect you from
unbearable emotional pain and if you
just took the time to listen to it and
love it back it might become your
greatest gift
these 30 days were a great learning
experience i encourage you to try it out
for yourself and thanks so much for
watching i'll see you in the next one